hey everybody what's up you guys have
been requesting new spider-man
homecoming so today we're going to talk
all about the vulture
he's one of the coolest members of the
Sinister Six Michael Keaton is going to
be bad at if you're new to the channel
i'm going to be doing a whole bunch of
spider-man videos this year both of the
comics both for the movies the TV shows
there's even a new spider-man TV show
that's coming up so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and is a giveaway
going on that i'll explain at the end of
the video so here's ten really cool
things you need to know about the
vulture number 10
Michael Keaton is most known for his
role as Batman it's something that
followed him around his entire career he
said many times since he's come back to
acting he took a break to raise his
family but has come back with a
vengeance in is always happy to joke
about his time as batman lego jackass do
it yourself in the mirror and say i'm
batman 17 18 times a day
Batman in fact the reason he said he
left the franchise is because he got a
whiff of joel schumacher's Batman
why does Batman always have to be so
serious he literally heard them say that
instead of that was the cue for him to
leave so goodbye Batman number nine
enter the Birdman 2014 Keaton also started a
movie called Birdman which won several
Oscars Kim himself was nominated for
Best Actor it was an amazing movie but a
lot of you might think this is a funny
coincidence because he's trading one
bird costume for another but it goes way
deeper than that the movie itself is a
dark comedy about the blurring of the
characters personal and professional
lives he's that old washed-up actor who
used to be incredibly famous for playing
a superhero called Birdman starting to
sound familiar right
the filmmakers turned it into a parody
of the Batman franchise and of course
Keaton being a total champ was more than
happy to oblige in order to show how the
character could always tell what was
real from what was fake
sometimes his Birdman self would appear
to him behind and slide around speaking
to him in a really crazy superhero voice
is super trippy the Birdman voice the
key used when he was in the costume
flying around was the same batman voice
that he used during the Tim Burton film
he says it was a big joke between him
and the director he's like yeah go for
it
use the batman voice and of course he
was totally happy to do it
number eight origins vulture is one of
spider-man's oldest villains in the
comics spider-man debuted in amazing
fantasy number 15 in 1962 vulture debut
in spider-man's for solo title amazing
spider-man number two in 1963 that next
year one of the very first big villains
the basic setup is that you don't know
much about his backstory just started
out as a villain for spider-man defeat
he's been terrorizing New York City with
this artificial harness looking like a
vulture
so Peter Parker decides to photograph
the criminal in action selling the
photographs will help pay for aught may
make ends meet so he's got his big break
spider-man tracks vulture to his hideout
before he
doing a big jewel robbery but ends up
getting his ass handed to him so he
hobbles home and fixes his gear makes
his gadgets a little bit better goes
back and is finally able to take him
down
does that not look like something that
happens during this trailer they're here
at Coney Island spider-man is in his old
costume he got his ass handed to him and
then later in the film we see him saving
that Staten Island theory with the new
start text suit seven tragic origins
like a lot of villains he starts out is
a relatively good person who falls on
hard times
he's an electrician and engineer working
with his partner at BNP electronics
investment in tombs investment steals
his money cut him out of the business so
tombs is forced to turn to a life of
crime to support himself was a bit of a
long haul before they pay that off
because Stanley wrote that original
story about him just being a random
spider-man villain with wings on it was
nineteen eighty-three before they called
back to him getting revenge on that
partner investment for investment in
tombs electronics number six what a
coincidence
he was a founding member of the Sinister
Six an amazing spider-man annual number
one in 1964 Doctor Octopus breaks out of
prison and gathers Mysterio electro
Kraven the hunter culture and Sandman to
get revenge against spider-man teaming
up to form the Sinister Six spider-man
has lost his powers so he's trying to
hide out in lay low till he can regain
his identity
what ends up happening is that he fight
each of the members of the Sinister Six
one at a time through different
facilities
what a coincidence the first fight that
he has is that a stark industries power
plant
he faces electro what a coincidence that
iron man is in this movie there's going
to be a lot of startech things he even
offers to help spider-man in the comic
book issue he fights Craven and Central
Park who has three Tigers he has to take
down he's offered help by the Human
Torch you can see there's a theme here
where he needs a bunch of his friends
along the way he says no I'm going to do
this by myself
it's my chance to be a hero also in
keeping with the tone of the spider-man
homecoming trailer so that's all come
back around but he fights Mysterio he
bites and man he fight Fulcher working
his way up the boss letter to Dr Octopus
number 5 culture can be super creepy
when he wants to be if he doesn't
already looked creepy during superior
spider-man spider-man tracks him down
and think that he might be using midgets
to commit crimes
this is the doctor octopus version of
spider-man when he was in control of
spider-man's body so he's already
horrified by this doctor octopus is
horrified by something that the vulture
is doing but then he realizes it's even
worse the vulture has been using small
children to commit crimes something the
other members of the Sinister Six would
never stoop to
so if the Sinister Six things that you
are creepy you're probably pretty creepy
number for civil war call back from the
comics even though the movie Civil War
was different from comic book Civil War
vulture actually got to work for the
government doing something good by
bringing in the criminal spider-man
after he rebelled against Iron Man Iron
Man took the side of the government
spider-man took captain america side he
switch sides during the middle of the
conflict even though it wasn't that way
in the movie so the vulture was hired to
bring spider-man in so even though he's
still relatively evil Dark Reign style
he got to pretend or make believe that
he was good number three there have been
five different versions of the vulture
in the comics even though the movie
version is going to be Adrian Toomes the
original there was Blackie Drago clifton
shallot Bulgarians and then Jimmy taille
so blocky Drago was to cellmate in
prison he tried to trick him into giving
in the harness but eventually two men
got out of prison and retook the mantle
then later another scientist named
clifton shallots mutated into an actual
vulture but actually had real wings
it was a little more like ultimate
spider-man with the more freakish
looking green goblin situation the other
latest one back in 2019 matali which is
this low-level mobster who is also
mutated into this freakish looking
actual vulture creature so tombs was the
only one that wore the harness the
others were actually mutated into real
vultures
number two he went full-on vampire for a
little while he actually got this serum
in 1994 during amazing spider-man number
386 called Juba nadir you can imagine
what that does that allowed him to drain
the life force from living beings when
he touched them with special got--let so
it's basically like a version of Dracula
flying around in the vulture harness so
you can imagine is draining spider man's
life force they actually did this a
little bit during spiderman the animated
series in the nineties but eventually
the effects wore off any becomes an old
man again in number one this is not
their first attempt to put vulture in a
spider-man movie this is the fourth time
they try to get him in and obviously the
only time that it's stuck you would have
remembered if they put him in a previous
movie the first time they tried to get
him in a spider-man movie was during
spider-man three sam raimi's last movie
the studio decided to switch him out for
venom at the last minute so if you've
got that movie was over stuff with
villains and you didn't like that
portrayal of venom that could have been
the vulture but I don't know that would
have been any better or not the second
time they try to do vulture was in the
fourth spider-man movie that Sam Raimi
was originally going to do before he
left the franchise the third time was
when they did the amazing spider-man
reboot they were getting ready to ramp
up to Sinister Six you saw the vulture
harness in the background sort of an
easter egg
he was going to appear in the sony
Sinister Six movie which kind of went by
the wayside they're still making it
eventually but is there just now going
out the brand new spider-man don't
expect to see it anytime soon but of
course sony is aggressively moving on
spider-man IP so they will try to make a
sinister six movie once they develop all
these brand new characters in homecoming
what's going to happen next is absolute
flash to post there's some new Wonder
Woman areas you guys have asking me for
so get that out as fast as possible but
there is a new round of the spider-man
giveaway I'm actually giving away copies
of the doctor strange DVD so it should
be dr. strange but all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Kim's asuka please private
message me on the back into my channel
so i can get your contact details while
you wait for that you can click here for
my non-spoilery Logan review and you can
click
here for my black pants video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five
I'll see you in the next video